festejos con restricciones y sin gente
en las calles el fin de año de 2020 será
recordado como el más raro en la memoria
francia no recibirá el 2021 con
celebraciones como quinto país a nivel
mundial en contagios los tradicionales
fuegos artificiales de los campos
elíseos han sido anulados cien mil
policías se encargarán de hacer cumplir
un toque de queda entre las ocho de la
tarde y las seis de la mañana y las
reuniones públicas están prohibidas la
cuna de la nueva variante del virus
reino unido también se enfrenta a duras
medidas sociales y se quedará sin el
espectáculo pirotécnico que la gente
observado desde las orillas del támesis
también alemania suele ser sinónimo de
espectáculo de pirotecnia para despedir
el año pero no esta vez tanto las
reuniones como los espectáculos en
lugares públicos están prohibidos
durante el 31 de diciembre y el 1 de
enero en este duro 2020 estén que yo
creo que no estoy exagerando cuando digo
nunca en los últimos 15 años hemos
pensado que el año viejo había sido tan
pesado como este y nunca a pesar de las
preocupaciones y el escepticismo
esperado tanto y con tanta esperanza el
año nuevo al otro lado del atlántico la
situación no es mejor en eeuu el primer
país del mundo en casos y número de
muertes nueva york ha cerrado times
square y la gente tendrá que festejar
desde sus casas o virtualmente brasil el
tercero en la cola de contagios tampoco
verá desde las orillas de río de janeiro
el clásico despliegue de fuegos
artificiales a medida que el país sigue
registrando un número récord de muertes
la crisis también se extiende a colombia
que se aproxima a los 43 mil decesos
impondrá ley seca y toque de queda en
las principales ciudades del país para
contener el virus méxico a pesar de ser
pionero en vacunación en la región está
desde hace semanas en semáforo rojo
epidemiológico y para fin de año la
economía no esencial permanecerá cerrada
en los principales estados con esta
situación a nivel global las esperanzas
en el año nuevo están puestas en la
aplicación de vacunas